all right guys bang bang i've got a
super exciting episode for you i've got
chris larson here with me the co-founder
and executive chairman of ripple and
then in a personal capacity he is one of
the participants in a brand new campaign
called change the code not the climate
chris thanks so much for coming on and
spend some time talking
thanks for having me appreciate it
for sure so one of the areas is
obviously i don't think you or i are
confused this is uh a lot of people are
paying attention they want to understand
what the hell does chris think what does
pomp think do they agree do they
disagree and all the details but i do
think it's important to start off with
uh across the industry every single
community seems to have these you know
kind of black and white sunglasses on
there is no common ground in any way
i think that both you and i have some
areas where we vehemently agree on and
so uh would it be fair to say that you
know you see a lot of problems in the
legacy financial system and generally
you think that crypto as an industry uh
could create some of those solutions to
solve those problems is that like a fair
middle ground where we probably agree
greatly
absolutely and i'm glad you brought that
up because i think by and large look
people in crypto were trying to change
the world in a very positive way there's
there's so much opportunity here this
thing's just begin uh beginning
and i want nothing more than the
industry to succeed because the system
that we have is broken and it's old and
antiquated it's hurting people so
absolutely
and i think another area that uh is
interesting to talk about because uh it
usually enters into the political room
but if we kind of put politics aside
it's this idea that like markets in
general we're talking about technology
startups we're talking about finance
talk about anything markets tend to be
self-correcting in some form or fashion
uh and they end up deciding who winners
and losers are which i think every
entrepreneur and investor which you know
this isn't your first company this isn't
the first time that you found success in
technology or finance um but that seems
to be a theme that most entrepreneurs
kind of get behind is that another kind
of fair uh point where we end up uh
seeing eye to eye
yeah i think generally markets do uh
determine what wins and what doesn't um
i do in my opinion i do believe there's
a lot of luck into it as well right
silicon valley we sometimes say uh yeah
that person got hit by the electric
truck right so it's a combination of
those things
probability is a huge factor in life but
uh some people don't like to admit that
so uh that's for sure uh and then the
other piece that i think actually we see
eye to eye on which is funny because
it's a difference is we're both highly
biased as is everyone else watching this
and kind of participating in this market
whenever there's money involved uh or
assets it seems like uh just naturally
as humans we tend to gravitate if i own
more bitcoin then you know i like
bitcoin if i own more uh xrp or ethereum
or whatever there's kind of this tribal
element and so um for me i am you know
95 of my liquid net worth is in bitcoin
uh which obviously skews the way that i
view things whether that's good or bad
uh for you how do you think about your
portfolio and like how much is in crypto
versus uh if there's any sort of um kind
of breakdown across assets that you
normally try to target
yeah boy i don't know but 75 is probably
in crypto and obviously the vast
majority of that is uh you know as you
probably know is in the xrp um but you
know yeah finance is a funny it's a
funny place right it is super
competitive um in a way that's almost
fun right people people like the
competition
um and in crypto more so than any other
place because it was built by
libertarians libertarians uh probably
don't do a good job of forming
communities right so
that's just the way it is
but when we're talking about climate
though that's kind of a different beast
so um
that's what i spend most of my time on
that is not about
my assets that's about you know that's
about the planet i'm leaving for my kids
and and that's a different beast
got it and so
obviously the reason why we're recording
this and kind of uh over the last i
don't know 48 72 hours whatever it's
been there's lots of people who are
paying attention to a brand new campaign
my understanding is uh it's called not
uh change the code not the climate and
uh there's a number of different i'll
call them uh esg or environmental groups
just as a blanket way to describe a
number of these organizations some of
them seem to be for-profit some are
non-profit but they all have a general
sense they care about the environment
they want to see positive impact on the
environment and maybe just explain a
little bit what is the campaign and then
how do you think about your
participation in the campaign as a
private individual
yeah so the campaign is um specifically
around uh the issue of um
you know kind of bitcoin's contribution
to the climate crisis and again look let
me start off with saying uh i am pro
bitcoin i want bitcoin to succeed
bitcoin's been the most i think it's
been the most successful financial asset
of all time right tens of millions of
people own it it's important for the
overall crypto community that bitcoin
continued to succeed and i think it will
um but it's it's important to people
because it's held by so many folks so
just let me say that right off the top
um
but the problem is uh as bitcoin gets
more successful
the contribution to the climate crisis
gets worse and and that is the heart of
the problem and we believe that can be
solved with changing the code again not
easy to do and we're not advocating a
certain type of change we're not saying
it has to do with ethereum has done that
could be an outcome but we're not
advocating for that we know it's a
different community
um but come on i gotta believe all the
smart people all the trillions of
dollars floating around in this industry
that
can't we get to a place we can change
the code so that as bitcoin gets
successful it doesn't harm
the climate
you know at least neutral but maybe even
massively negative i believe you could
do that
we do all kinds of super hard stuff we
can do that so we're going to get to
some of the nuance of this in a second
um i guess one of the big questions
right and uh frankly i think that uh the
media loves a story like this right it's
like hey we've got somebody who is
incredibly successful in an industry
who's saying let's change something and
that change could frankly be all kinds
of different things they love to kind of
gravitate towards it we saw a whole
bunch of articles and i think one of the
main questions people had for me was
like hey how does chris think about his
participation right so obviously i think
i read that there's about five million
dollars you're putting into the
advertising how does this group come
together is this like uh like some sort
of uh
you know quarterly meeting that these
groups have and this was one of the
ideas that they came up with is it
something where uh they think that
there's economic benefit or just walk me
through kind of how does this specific
coalition come together in your mind
yeah well as you probably know i mean
the climate issue around bitcoin has
been out there for some time i've
written about it now for i guess a year
and a half
and now what's happening is there's the
because of all the mining is that's
coming to the u.s you know 65 percent of
it used to be in china now most of it's
in the u.s you're seeing these small
communities that are objecting to some
of the practices so seneca lake for
example and that's where it started
where uh you know a retired coal plant
now it's a gas plant being used for
bitcoin mining kentucky you're seeing a
ton of stuff going on there with fossil
fuels and people upset about it at the
local level same in pennsylvania and
then that's triggering some of the
bigger organizations to get wind of this
because these small groups are
approaching them greenpeace
environmental working group for example
and the ex-head of the sierra club mike
brune who's actually running the
campaign they start getting aware of the
issue and you know we kind of came
together because i spend most of my time
on climate issues
um
all kinds of things green hydrogen
trying to get republicans and democrats
to work on climate together all kinds of
things
but this is one of them and it's in my
own backyard so can't ignore it and so i
just think it's a matter of time this
this issue isn't going away it's just
going to get worse this isn't going to
be the first campaign and the campaign
is really good let's get awareness first
there's some awareness but there's also
some misinformation let's get awareness
that's a problem then hey let's get
people working
on solutions
and then if there's a good solution
let's get people to
see if they can adopt it right simple as
that um but i think my participation is
probably healthy i mean it'd be better
to have a crypto person in one of these
campaigns than not there's plenty of
climate billionaires out there many of
them are anti-crypto can you imagine
warren buffett was
you know back in this that wouldn't be
good right even bill gates fairly
anti-crypto
i think it's better to have somebody
that look i believe in it and i say that
on these press conferences even if some
of the other folks
are not as enthusiastic i think that's a
i think that's a plus
got it and so when these things come
together i i frankly uh this is probably
the first one that i've actually looked
at and try to understand you know how
they work and it seems like uh your
contribution has been the five million
dollars for the ad campaigns itself to
kind of go by advertising across the
these various platforms is there money
that changes hands with like the green
piece and the other organizations or how
does that work like what what other than
the positive impact on the environment
are there other reasons why these groups
do it together rather than do it
separately or is it just their safety in
numbers or kind of power numbers
well yeah it's a great point um they all
do some
things a little bit differently so some
of them might be more policy based some
are they're going to be more grassroots
roots based like greenpeace for example
three million members uh that's what
they're really really strong at a person
like mike bruhn used to run the sierra
club just great at building coalitions
and by the way that's coalitions like
reaching out to uh owners of coal plants
right people that run energy companies
this is not just
um you know kind of monochromatic you
know environmentalists right you've got
to get everybody together working on
this that's a big part of this campaign
too we've got to reach out to
uh the people that are deeply involved
in bitcoin and you know look at it
religiously even right that's that's
going to be important this is not anti
anything this is about hey there here's
a problem
the problem the way it's going it's
going to get worse climate's getting
worse we had a million and a half acres
of
forest burn last year in california
all-time record you can barely get
insurance in many places in california
uh this is bad right things are getting
worse
um so that's the nature of the campaign
you try to get a good coalition with
different skills
the more folks you have the better i
think and in any campaign like this
um i think it's off to a good start
there'll be other campaigns that i'm you
know i have no idea about but you know
this is just ramping up in my opinion
got it so i've got about 10 questions or
so as i was telling you before we
started to record uh i put out a tweet
and uh i thought i would just get some
tweets back i figured you and i we would
probably laugh at most of them uh and
all of a sudden i got emails i got text
message i got a phone call there was
multiple people who were very interested
and they send me all kinds of things
what i've tried to do is uh take all of
those different uh inquiries if you will
and put them into major themes into
these ten questions and so uh i'm just
gonna go through one by one almost maybe
not rapid fire you just you know you
take your time to to respond but but i
think uh uh it's fair to give you a
chance to kind of respond to these uh so
the first one is do you agree that a
decentralized digital currency
regardless of which one it is is a net
positive for the world and could be a
potential solution too many of the
legacy finance uh issues
oh 100 yeah absolutely um i don't think
these things replace fiat because every
country wants to have their own currency
of course
but they serve a fundamentally different
uh purpose in the world right they
lubricate the world's economy right
something uh a thing of value without a
counterparty or issuer
is extremely valuable and what's what
we're seeing is that's why these things
are worth trillions of dollars and
look i think i think bitcoin will con
especially if it fixes this issue
it will be a little more valuable than
gold right it will get there for sure
but i think uh it has to fix this issue
but
the market has spoken right there's no
question and everybody that pooh-poohed
it
warren buffett right jamie diamond like
you name it charlie munger they were
wrong right the price continues to go up
the use cases continue to go up these
things are incredibly important to the
world
so i think this is a layup but uh there
was a whole bunch of other questions
around like do you think that the
digital currency that ends up being used
globally has to be secure as well and
then as a kind of you know question
number two related to that what do you
think is the most secure consensus
mechanism in the world if you had to
just forget all of the other impacts or
potential trade-offs if it was just
optimizing for security when do you
think it has to be secure and then two
what do you think is the most secure
mechanism to reach consensus in a
blockchain
well it absolutely has to be asked to be
secure and and and you know like i take
it i saw you you tweeted about hey we're
never going to change proof of work okay
look if if that means we're never going
to change how secure
uh bitcoin is and proof of work is today
i agree with that don't give up on the
security it has to be absolutely secure
but my point is
can't we can't we replicate that
security
uh
but do it in a way that is not
contributing climate or making maybe
even helping solve climate i think you
can do that right i don't know how to do
it but i have faith that the world can
figure that out right but you're right
you can't give up on security absolutely
critical important as far as which one's
most secure well look i think the market
is speaking um if you look at non-proof
of work about a trillion dollars there i
guess uh over 10 years the market has
basically said yeah we believe in it we
believe that's secure enough and we're
putting money where our mouth is so
i don't know i haven't seen any data
that would quantify one over the other
but i get it
this is super valuable within the
bitcoin community so
like don't go to proof of stake fine but
could you can you rethink proof of work
so you get rid of this problem where the
price goes up climate gets worse the
price went up and climate got better
this would be the definition of a carbon
coin it's the only and by the way the
only one can do that because it's got
the mining infrastructure nobody else
has that mining infrastructure is going
in the wrong direction right now no
fault of miners just being incented to
do that could you change the code and
make that go the other way
everybody in the world would want to own
that i'm telling you this this is the
thing i don't get
why the bitcoin committee doesn't see
that
so i i think what i heard is uh
right now bitcoin is the most secure but
if there was a security mechanism that
came along that was more secure
uh or didn't hurt the environment if you
had both of those if you could be secure
and not hurt the environment
according to whatever analysis then that
would be the ideal scenario but right
now we basically have the most secure
and your concern isn't so much it's not
secure it is secure it's more so just
the negative impact on the environment
in your opinion well what i'm going to
say is is like the bitcoin community
believes that this is the most secure i
haven't seen data what do you think
that's what they want to know they want
to know what you think though i think i
look at the market the market is
probably is saying look of those top you
know number you know whether it's proof
proof of stake is the market's saying
it's secure it's banking
500 billion dollars on ethereums alone
as it switches right so anyway i think
the market is speaking there but look i
get it uh you can make the case the
proof will work the way it is now that's
the security that you want
fine and i agree with you don't give up
on that never give up on that but i
don't get the and i don't think you were
saying this correctly am i wrong i don't
think you were saying never change what
satoshi put in there in the first place
right because climate thing wasn't
really a problem way back then
now it's a problem right and things have
to innovate right um so like the idea of
never change right
i mean come on satoshi didn't say never
right people told him never right elon
never said he didn't say never right
people told him never the silicon valley
was built on never right miami was built
on never new york vegas you know this is
america right he
things because there's a problem and we
know how to change that we know how to
fix things so that's all i'm saying
there but uh so i i think we kind of
agree on that i think curriculum the
only thing i'll disagree with and we'll
move on because i know we got a whole
bunch of stuff to talk about is when uh
i agree that ethereum says they're gonna
move to proof of stake but i think the
key piece is that bitcoin and ethereum
since inception both have been proof of
work they're the only two blockchains
that have reached positions one and two
and stayed there right everything else
kind of has fallen to the way where the
market thinks their value at one point
and they go away uh ethereum is saying
that they're gonna move to proof of
stake right now they still are based on
proof of work and we don't know if they
transition and let's say with hindsight
buy it benefit 20 years from now if all
of a sudden ethereum fell out of the top
you know coins because they made that
transition we would think one thing if
they stay there we may think another and
so unfortunately you i or the market
doesn't have that hindsight benefit
today but i think up until today it's
been proof of work and there's a
question mark if they transition what's
going to happen bitcoiners obviously
think that's bad i think the ethereum
community thinks it's good and you know
going back to this idea the market will
be the referee i think we just got to
see what happens at the market
i think i probably agree with that yeah
that's that's fair okay all right we're
i'm telling you we're going to end up
agreeing on here more that than uh than
we think uh all right so uh when you
look at it there's tons of studies out
there around how much the bitcoin
network actually is consuming uh what is
your like what study or what data point
do you use if you had to measure it on
like the global energy consumption is
there a number that you point to i
usually look at the number that is 0.1
of total global energy consumption what
do you use when thinking about this yeah
we use
cambridge university's numbers which
lays it out but they come in about a
half a percent and that's really
importantly that's
end user electricity right i think
correctly i'm wrong i'd be interested to
know your denominator and your numerator
um but i think if you're using base
primary energy coming into a country
that would be like the theoretical
energy com
content of a barrel of oil you know you
got to convert that to electricity or
other things you lose most of it in the
conversion so the relevant number should
be electricity that's usable by end
users right and that's also really
important in climate because the world
has to electrify everything right that's
the that's the challenge here it's
incredibly hard it's going to take a
long time and then so that total global
number is going to be 23 peta uh watt
hours right and bitcoin's coming in at
130 terawatt hours that's about half a
percent
so when you think about this one of the
things that to me is fascinating is even
if transaction fees exploded which is
part of the miner's revenue even if
bitcoin's price exploded and so there
was a bigger economic incentive for
people to mine and today you know
there's 40 million dollars or so miners
are being paid per day uh globally if
that exploded upwards and it went to 200
billion dollars right in a given year
that they were actually pulling in from
a uh
from an economic incentive standpoint
the thing that i always jumped to is
like even with that 200 billion dollars
of economic incentive they couldn't buy
more than one percent of the global
energy right just 200 billion dollars as
their revenue if they went and spend
every single dollar buying energy and so
they made no profit it still would only
get you about 0.9
based on the numbers i've looked at so
how do you think about
even with the revenue that they get it
ends up just being a limiting factor on
how much energy they could purchase in
the future
well i don't get where you're coming
from with that i mean they could set up
shop in saudi arabia and basically you
know be the number one customer right if
the saudis want to do that look the the
big problem is the big number right now
130 trillion watt hours but that's up 10
action five years that's the alarming
part here right and why is that because
the price has gone up right you had two
havings in those five years by the way
you go out another five years of that
you're going to be using more
electricity and then japan right you're
going to be at one uh pedowatt hour um
that's four percent of the world's elect
use end user electricity right that's a
problem that's a big problem you look at
people fighting climate you can't ignore
that right and again i would just say
like if that happens like that's in five
years
where's climate in five years it's going
to be worse right because we're way
behind the curve here
there's just no way that companies and
liquidity providers aren't going to be
just they're going to be picking it
they're going to be scared to death it's
gonna be like what happened in russia
here where all these you know it's not
just sanctions but the companies move
out
and that's gonna be devastating to the
growth of bitcoin that's what you hit
that wall right so that's why change the
code and change the proof of work don't
go to of stake change the proof of work
flip the equation there right you got
that mining infrastructure is
that is nobody else has that imagine
those things sucking carbon out of the
if they were incented to suck carbon out
or maybe produce renewable energies now
like i get it right right now you've got
a beautiful solution and you don't don't
have to prove the work the result proves
the work right it's math
um you got to figure out a different way
if you're going to be counting co2
sucked out or renewable energy pumped in
for free to the grid imagine you had
that right but again bottom line if
people can make money
like they have been on bitcoin and it's
helping the climate that's unstoppable
that's carbon coin that's the mythical
carbon coin right there so so to get to
four percent energy consumption globally
it would cost about 800 billion dollars
and the miners just don't have that
money i think that's where the bitcoin
community says well hold on a second
like even if fees spiked and bitcoin
went up 100
they literally wouldn't have enough
money to buy four percent of global
energy and so i think that when i look
at this the other key piece to this is
that the legacy finance system i think
you and i both uh would agree on this is
pretty non-controversial the more users
the more transactions the more
transaction volume the more energy
consumption there's a very linear
relationship right you need more atms
you need more banks you need more data
centers all this type of stuff to
support more users
with bitcoin one of the interesting
things is that the layer one a single
line or a single transaction in that
block could represent me sending you one
bitcoin so two-party transaction a
single transaction or it could represent
billions of dollars of economic value
and hundreds of transactions on the
layer 2 like in the lightning network
and so if we scale out the lightning
network at the layer 2 now all of a
sudden there is not a linear
relationship to support more users or
more transactions we don't actually need
to consume more power how do you think
about that as one of the bitcoiners
arguments in terms of why there isn't
this linear relationship between more
users and more energy consumption well
first of all i disagree with your first
calculation there look if the prices
or if the energy uses up 10x that's if
it's four percent yeah you can you can
buy that energy you can afford it's it's
proportional to what you're seeing today
right it's the same equation they're
going to spend up to you know
some profit margin and and that's the
driver um as far as you know kind of
this one transaction look you're still
securing the network there's still this
race to solve that uh that puzzle and
people are going to spend up until the
point where they make a they make a
decent return the thing is like yeah
you're right the legacy systems use
energy
but they need to be working and many of
them are to reduce it as much as they
can and the only point here is so does
so this is a bitcoin protocol again it's
in there it's in the interest of the
bitcoin community to do that right and
if you can invent
a better form of proof of work for
example
uh that either gets to neutral or gets
to negative it's the holy grail right um
then do it right why aren't we doing
that that's the thing i don't get
the trillions of dollars in this
industry right the billions of dollars
the miners were why aren't why is there
a crack team here that's supported by
the the bitcoin mining association
that's all they're doing is they're
working on a new
breakthrough code base that would solve
this problem well there's so much money
there's so much talent
we can do this right but i think why are
we doing it yeah i think the big thing
so using your example without any
havings if there was still 900 bitcoin
per day coming in and price was up 10x
so the minor revenue was up 10x it would
still only be 146 billion dollars and so
if miners went and spent every single
dollar on energy
they still couldn't buy one percent of
the global energy so 10x increase in
price 146 billion dollars of total minor
revenue globally in a given year they
couldn't spend all 146 billion and buy
one percent and i think that's where one
of the big questions is you know maybe
energy costs come down
some way but i just it's hard for me to
see them getting their hands on 800
billion dollars spending 100 of it and
buying four percent of the energy
production you're using a different
denominator you're using that primary
incoming you know theoretical energy in
a barrel of oil for example the relevant
number in my opinion should be you know
cambridge university number which is the
electricity use that's again 23 peta
watt hours whatever it is um also by the
way if it goes up 10x the price is
probably more than that you got to
having in there but again track record
is 10x in five years continue that out
and look i believe anybody who said
price isn't going to continue to i don't
buy it i think it will like the track
record is there we have to assume the
problem gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and they can't afford
it because the money's there
so if we look you i think that the data
you use let's use your data you said
that the energy consumption's up 10x in
the last five years right
the price is up 4 373
so as the price explodes upwards if
price only goes up 10x the increase in
energy consumption will be minuscule
compared to the price increase at least
what we've seen over the last five years
if it repeats moving forward so let's
keep going because i know there's
there's other things here uh and i don't
think we're gonna agree on everything
which is okay right uh but but let's
keep going fair enough
um all right so one of the big things
that uh i saw people all day pretty much
on twitter uh when you guys announced
the campaign they were like look maybe
chris is right maybe they're not who
knows but why don't they just fork the
bitcoin code and allow the market to
decide what was the thought process in
terms of running the campaign
versus just going and forking the code
making any changes that you thought or
the rest of the group thought would be
applicable and then allowing the market
to decide what was valuable
well first of all i'm not that smart and
i don't have that much energy anymore so
and nobody would trust me to do
something like that so uh no this is
about one awareness let's get awareness
uh of the problem the climate problem
the contribution here and then yeah like
can you inspire like come on let's make
a code change and again a code change
consistent with the values of bitcoin
community but come on i gotta believe
whether it's the core developers who
come up with this whether it's a minors
association hey a smart teenager in
cambodia right a math teacher in the in
ukraine i mean the world can do this
right they can figure this out but we
got to start working on it that's the
only point we're trying to make i can't
do that but there's brilliant people out
there and everybody's dialed into crypto
right now the whole world is so we can
come up with something better
okay
now there was a uh a line in a bloomberg
article that i read uh and the line was
the campaign believes that about 50 key
miners crypto exchanges and core
developers have the power to change
bitcoin's code now as you can imagine
this was probably the one thing in all
of the articles that i saw people
getting the most worked up about uh i
saw everything from like who are the 50
people right to uh how do you
how do you not include node operators
after we saw the block size wars etc
just
maybe to to kind of uh make this
valuable for folks who are listening how
do you think the code would be changed
do you agree with the statement that
there's 50 miners and exchanges and
people that could do this do you think
that maybe that was a uh overstatement
or just walk me through kind of that the
process of actually changing it if there
was a change that you thought was uh
applicable yeah question i mean go back
to you know there's a book out recently
about the block size wars right you look
at kind of some of the
the the battles there i don't know what
you might call kind of family dispute in
2015 right i mean you know back then you
know if you look some of the medium
posts and kind of what we're supporting
it's like 30 to 50
info it's called influential people
you're right they don't have the power
to unilaterally do anything
but they're influential right so they
got behind something could they convince
other people in the community that we
should hey we got to do this right uh
you know how to segue you know come
about right that kind of a thing so it's
an influential thing certainly that can
come internally and that would be a look
like a soft fork can come externally and
it could be a hard fork who knows that's
you know hopefully that doesn't go that
way but um these things can be done
you're right they're
they're they're not you know it's it's
uh
kind of messy right but um but again
if it's in the interest of the community
these things can be done
and change is a good thing sometimes
right i get it concert being
conservative
is important when you talk about finance
but these are cutting ed technology
where the very beginning is like 13
years in why are we stopping innovating
right now it doesn't make sense
you can do better
as a related point to this how do you
think about the importance of node
operators especially in a decentralized
system like bitcoin and having the
checks and balances between the
developers the miners the node operators
like what the role of the node operators
which obviously they played a crucial
role in the outcome of what happened the
block size wars how do you think about
their importance in something like this
is that the the key group to go and
convince uh to get a change push through
or what
yeah i mean it depends what their role
is right are they in exchange or just
you know somebody with an interest in
the network right so probably in
exchange probably goes along with their
customers right of fidelity for example
say hey look we've got to get on this
new code base because this improves uh
the climate situation that might be
influential to one validator if it's
just a validator let's say hey we're
just going to hold the line we're never
going to change and that's a different
com you know that's a different
calculation calculus but it is very
important right because they can reject
uh you know something that might happen
from that that core group um you have to
convince them you have to it's
influencing them and and motivating them
that this is a positive and not not
something that's going backwards
uh one of the other themes was basically
uh the conversation that you've had have
you talked with exchange ceos have you
talked with the black rocks the
fidelities etc what has been their
reaction if you have spoken to them uh
what any insights there
yeah i mean i don't want to you know
actually name names that wouldn't be
appropriate but we have spoken with a
number of folks including minors and
looks the minors are doing are being
really responsible you know you look at
argo and
riot and giffon
they're doing the right thing with
renewables the problem is the code
doesn't say anything about renewables
right the code just says
incense
cheap energy right so the saudis said
we're getting in the mining tomorrow
all those taxes they all the mining
going on texas move over to saudi arabia
with saudi arabia and be fossil fuels
and it'd be super cheap right so i mean
some people
uh get it right and have said that um
but i get it this is a controversial
thing it's a big step
but look we're in unchartered waters
here with climate crisis and we got to
be fighting this thing on every single
front and it's one of the fronts
when you think about renewables uh
according to the eia i was looking this
up before and i didn't know what this
data point was but renewables in the
united states in 2020
they estimated that 12.6 percent of
total u.s energy consumption came from
renewables and 19.8
of electricity generation came from
renewables so i think you know if you
get a a 12 or 19 on a test in school you
get a f right and obviously we're trying
to move uh higher and higher on that uh
but the bitcoin mining council which is
the only data that i've really seen
where people have kind of opened kimono
and said hey here's our energy mix they
report the members of that that about 66
of their energy consumption comes from
renewables so kind of 3x what the u.s
does how do you think about that in
terms of those members saying we are
using renewables we aren't having kind
of this negative impact uh compared to
what maybe the standard is across the
united states for energy consumption
i don't buy that number i mean look the
truth is you're seeing coal plants being
repurposed in kentucky a lot of them
right they're actually being incented
you're seeing waste coal being used in
pennsylvania jesus christ i mean that's
worse than regular coal so yeah there's
a lot of bad stuff going on out there i
don't buy that renewable number i
actually moved from china looked like
the
renewables went down because you lost
all the hydro right um and again the
code does not say anything about using
renewables it says
it incensed cheapest energy right and
look uh fossil fuels you'll always find
cheap fossil fuels somewhere in the
world they're going to be lower costs
than the really that's the problem as
far as the u.s uh depends on the state
california's higher hawaii is way higher
for example people are moving in the
right direction but you raise a good
point i mean we need to be getting on
top of nuclear and way more nuclear not
everybody in our coalition agrees with
that but that's fine but uh you know we
gotta we gotta be stepping on this much
more aggressively than we are as a world
or we're we're in deep trouble here so
uh i'm cheating a little bit because i
looked all this up beforehand i don't
expect you to be an energy expert so
bear with me for a second i i uh
beforehand i googled and figuring out
we're gonna talk about renewables and
said renewable energy cheaper than
fossil fuels and the three things that
came up where there was a weforum.org
that said uh nearly two-thirds 62
of renewables were cheaper than the
cheapest new fossil fuels according to
the international renewable energy
agency
there was an article uh irena.org in
2021 in june that's a majority of new
renewables undercut cheapest fossil fuel
and then bloomberg had an article in
june of 2021 that said building new
renewables is cheaper than burning
fossil fuels and so take away for a
second bitcoin mining and all of this is
your work in the climate is the idea
that renewables are a major solution
there like how do you think about
renewables versus fossil fuel and like
the direction uh kind of a progress i
guess in the cost of doing this stuff
and the technology what are you seeing
there and is that a potential pathway
where if all the bitcoin miners got on
renewables you'd say hey you know great
job guys and let's move on to the next
challenge
well no there's there's yeah first of
all the bitcoin thing was all renewables
again
the code doesn't incent that but look
we've got a shortage of renewables we we
need that stuff for steel and concrete
and transportation every other use case
here right so if there's a use case
where you can eliminate the energy use
you got to do that first that's kind of
got 101 and climate um but
renewables are it's great to see the
trends right they are especially in the
us that's true right now but the
renewables in there they're lower costs
but that's not true everywhere in the
world right
like the saudis variable cost of oil is
like half a cent per kilowatt hour the
renewables are nowhere close to that and
again here's another problem if the code
incense the the use of the cheapest
energy and we are successful in this
decarbonization process
all of those fossil fuels are going to
be like no demand and price is super
cheap variable costs will be only
matters you can see
you know using bitcoin mining to mine it
monetize stranded fossil fuels that's a
problem um so you know but back to your
fossil fuel question is my belief also
in climate uh is
can we get to a circular economy in some
of the fossil fuels right can you turn
gas into ammonia and capture all the the
carbon right there pump it down into the
saudi desert uh that's a good thing you
create circular gasoline through solar
combining that with green hydrogen now
comes you know gasoline basically we got
to look at more of that kind of stuff we
can't be shy about that and there's some
controversy there so i don't know if i
can agree with you there but when you
talk about renewables fossil fuels can
be renewable with ccs i know that's
controversial but we got to be going
down that path too in my opinion what
just had a personal curiosity what was
your thoughts when you read uh exxon
mobil taking the uh the flare gas and uh
using that to mine bitcoin with the
partnership with those caruso energy or
uh maybe two or three months ago conoco
phillips they admitted hey we're mining
bitcoin as well using some of these uh
methods like what's your general thought
about these large energy producers in
the united states mining bitcoin but not
doing it from uh what i would consider
kind of normal primary uh energy
production but rather using gas flare
capture or something like that
yeah i think it's a problem right i mean
but one thing i think the the flare yeah
it's a relatively small looks like
that's not as successful as some of the
other things that are going on like what
argo is doing you know in texas with the
renewables that looks like much more
successful um so i don't know it's a
little bit of a
sidebar issue i guess but obviously uh
flaring gas or venting gas um for you
know flaring is better than venting it
but
better would be to have equipment
installed that prevents both of those uh
that's probably the path forward uh
it's negative you're producing carbon if
you use either one of those
got it uh what percentage chance do you
assign to the code actually getting
changed that was like one of the things
was like a bunch of people were just
asking me like does chris think he'll
actually be successful so like maybe
like is there a percentage or
probability that you say hey i think
this campaign could actually drive
change
well i guess it's a timeline right i
mean this will be years right so first
of all it's the awareness second of all
is can you you know get people inspired
to take a crack and maybe improve the
proof of workforce again i think that's
the better
process here right
can you get it to be negative i asked
holy grail
it's years uh you know but look what i
know though is
this is an unsustainable path climate's
getting worse
and bitcoin because it's so successful
is going to be contributing more if
there's a breaking point here right just
think how bad climate could get it
people start you know look at millions
people start dying and look there's the
climate refugee problem is already bad
like this could get really bad and there
will be no tolerance for anything that
contributes to it from corporate america
from wall street because people can be
still up in arms this is the biggest
risk for bitcoin to get straight and
that is fixed with a code change
when you see things like the us dollar
they're one of the memes in the bitcoin
community is you know they take a
picture of like the military industrial
complex going down uh uh ocean and
they're like look at how bad this is for
the environment in terms of protecting
uh us dollar hegemony or whatever the
the meme of the day is uh why not
advocate for change in the legacy system
given that it's such a larger consumer
of energy it's obviously way less
renewable et cetera why go to bitcoin
which is you know estimated on your
numbers half a percent of energy
consumption my number's point one
percent
you mean why not fight the government is
that what you're asking me no no we're
doing that somewhere else but anyway i
don't think you're fighting bitcoin
right i think what you're doing is
you're advocating for change right i
think that you've used those words and
so like why not advocate for change in
the way that the u.s government and the
u.s dollar system uh with their energy
consumption
well for the same reason i don't live in
washington dc and i live here in silicon
valley right the the future is coming
out up and like i don't want to say it's
just here in silicon valley but that's
silicon valley idea right anything's
possible it's an optimistic future
that's not what you see in governments
right and i think most bitcoin people
would agree with this right change is
going to come from
innovation um it's going to come from
people stepping up and doing crazy
things like
bitcoin's invention right there's a
crazy idea that's impossible that's why
it worked right so that's just my belief
that's where you're gonna get changed
got it um another i got two more
questions then we're done uh the first
one was um
given your concern with the climate and
the environment etc what do you do
personally to kind of change your
behavior so there were suggestions you
know obviously smart asses all the way
to serious ones everything from does he
not use a refrigerator or ac uh does he
promise to never get on a private jet
again all the way to are there certain
things that you actually do do to to
kind of curb uh or think other people
should do to curb energy consumption
from the the climate problem
yeah i mean i guess that's sort of
important but um
the bigger thing is being innovative
right i mean only like 15 of the problem
is even here and the rest of the world
isn't going to just do away with stuff
so the only solution there is innovation
right it's it's not like everybody's
going to go back to the stone age that's
it personally though i buy about 300
tons of carbon removal removal from
climb works pay a lot of money for that
700 bucks a ton
but i like that i don't i don't really
trust a lot of the offset markets
they're too cheap they're suspicious
that i don't buy it
but removal like things like claim works
is awesome company um that's pretty cool
we gotta we gotta get that way up right
we gotta get that to gigatons uh and
paying for that also helps them get the
gigatons down the line 15 years from
that right
got it and just for people who don't
know what that is like explain what uh
that the removal actually is how does
that work oh i'm sorry yes direct air
capture right so what they're basically
doing they're just they're sucking
cartman out of the air uh climb works
the swiss company uh they've got a big
operation in iceland now where they're
sucking out about uh
uh four kilotons 40 kilotons right now i
believe it is uh no i'm sorry it's it's
only four going up to 40 and then i
think it's 400
and then try to replicate thousands of
those all over the world it's really
exciting science fiction kind of stuff
but man if you can scale that that's a
huge part of the solution yeah it makes
uh makes sense um the last question and
this is the one that uh frankly
could be asked a million different ways
so i'm gonna leave it as open-ended as
possible and you kind of talk through it
as you uh want but there's lots of
people who uh essentially were
accusatory uh who outright were just
like hey ripple or it's executives or
the company they're responsible for this
entire
anti-bitcoin mining uh narrative etc and
i think the best way to kind of ask so
that you can really just elaborate on
how you guys think about this is
does ripple the executives or anyone
involved take specific uh uh
partnerships do you guys pay folks to to
kind of spread messages or like how do
you guys think about it when you
actually have something that you care
about right obviously you do other work
outside of the bitcoin mining advocating
uh for the climate how do you think
about dispersing that message and how
much of it is just going and talking to
people and educating them versus you
guys are paying for some of this stuff
etc
yeah well first of all this is this
campaign is personal right so ripple is
not a part of this but look i i get it
like uh again that you talked about at
the beginning uh this industry is tribal
i i knew when i participated in this
it'd be seen as a tribal attack um it's
not you know i want bitcoin to succeed
um the industry can't succeed if bitcoin
doesn't succeed right period right these
things kind of work they all kind of run
together
so um but you know the the climate issue
is real
um and it is something i've advocated
for um i've written about uh i talk to
people all the time um but i'm i'm
hoping i can do that in a constructive
way that's as a positive i also talk
about how important these things are to
succeed
and again bitcoin's held by tens of
millions of people you can't
you can't
go down a path where you're somehow
going to hurt those people right just
can't do that um you know so i think
speaking out i'm hoping people see that
as
is consistent like we can believe in it
i want it to succeed but i'm also
you know i think it's important for it
to change
so uh yes or no you guys actually pay
folks to to put this out like in terms
of some of the content how do you think
about because here's what this is me
thinking if i'm sitting in your seat if
i was to pay the 5 million dollars
i'm shocked that you said hey look i'm
the one who's providing the 5 million
dollars like i was like you know look
you got a comfortable life you've been
successful uh you basically open
yourself up to uh a lot of pushback and
questions and critiques et cetera and so
like how do you think about when to
participate financially versus not and
why put your name on it versus maybe not
and and uh
okay yeah a fair question um i think you
have to be transparent about that stuff
you know it's much worse if it kind of
comes out later or something ah i see
they were behind you know so it's like
straight up yeah i was the initial
funder for it um these groups were going
to be doing something anyway though but
you know a lot of this is coming it's
bubbling up from like the seneca lake
folks and the folks in kentucky and
folks in pennsylvania people are angry
because what they're seeing is seeing
like you know private equity funds
coming in and they're they're starting
up these plants and the and the prices
are going up and they're not getting any
benefit right so they're pissed right so
that's kind of where this is is really
bubbling up from but then the big the
big folks come in and yeah they do need
support if they're gonna you know make a
campaign these campaigns are actually
they're long they're brutal these guys
got a lot of things on their plate
already so yeah i do a lot of
philanthropy i've done 90 million in
climate philanthropy over the last
couple years
so yeah i'm gonna do that makes sense
and then i'm gonna be hoping about it i
uh i wish that i could ask you to stop
spending money on the uh on the
anti-bitcoin mining because then
bitcoiners have to go spend money on the
anti-anti-bitcoin mining but i don't
think we'll uh we'll reach that uh that
truce today
well you know look i i like the miners
are valuable like i think that's a
that's one of the
that's the secret sauce in bitcoin
actually nobody else has that but can
you turn it around right it goes the
other way oh my god i mean seriously
it's that's that's the holy grail that's
the that's the carbon coin think about
all this the new generation coming up i
can make money i can invest in my future
and i'm helping the climate while i'm
doing that that's unstoppable
yeah unstoppable i'm betting on you to
find the solution you identified the
problem in your eyes i need you to get a
solution out there all right i'll give
you the floor uh you got you know 30
seconds or whatever what do you want
people to take away from this in terms
of the campaign and kind of the position
that uh that you're taking
well i guess i want to be optimistic
about it it's like uh like i know all
the stuff on twitter that's bad for you
but look at um let's be excited about
this i'm optimistic this can be solved
this absolutely can be solved let's roll
up our sleeves let's get these groups
going to work on new code keep it as
proof of work keep the mining base but
but fix it so it's going the other way
that can be done we can totally do this
and
yeah um let's go for it
awesome well listen thank you so much
for uh for taking the time as i said to
a friend uh earlier today i said look
regardless of what you think he agreed
to come on and have the conversation
which uh which i respect greatly and uh
hopefully folks can take away from this
that uh although you and i may disagree
on some nuance here and there uh there's
definitely things that uh that we agree
on as well and so hopefully uh more and
more folks can have conversations like
this and uh you know the market will be
the uh the ultimate referee and uh we'll
see how it plays out so thanks so much
for uh for taking the time and uh
definitely have to do to get in the
future well thanks for being uh so kind
and thoughtful and inviting me over here
i really do appreciate that